[Music]
gummy vitamins were invented in the late
20th century by a couple looking for a
way to entice their daughter to take her
vitamins infused into a gummy candy
vitamins are now a sweet and chewy
experience for both kids and adults just
like gummy candies gummy vitamins come
in a variety of sweet and fruity flavors
making a vitamin a less bitter pill to
swallow each gummy vitamin starts with a
specific formula first raw ingredients
are selected and weighed some are in
liquid form and others are solids the
nutritional ingredients are blended with
water this particular batch is a
multivitamin preparation it includes
magnesium calcium and other minerals in
[Music]
a separate tank technicians prepare the
gelatin base which gives the vitamins a
jelly-like consistency next sugar and
gelatin premix is poured into the tank
the technician adds a sugar substitute
to the other ingredients meanwhile
specific amounts of water and glucose
are dispensed into the tank it takes
about five minutes to blend the
ingredients for the gelatin base then
the gummy vitamins ace is transferred to
a large holding tank in the lab the
nutritional mixture is tested for
contaminants such as heavy metals and
bacteria an automated syringe injects
the solutions into test tubes rinsing in
between injections now the samples in
the test tubes are ready to be analyzed
for heavy metal testing the sample is
injected into an extremely hot vacuum
chamber the plasma flame turns the metal
contaminants into atoms which the
machine reads as different colors the
machine also identifies and quantifies
contaminants
with the samples cleared for processing
they're ready for flavoring and colorant
more vitamins are added in powder form
to boost the formulas potency the liquid
vitamin preparation and the gelatin base
is piped into the mixing tank then
everything is blended together the
batter is now ready to be made into
thousands of gummy vitamins a conveyor
queues up the vitamin molds multiple
nozzles deposit precise amounts of
batter into small molds the conveyor
moves the tray forward as the gummy
vitamins begin to solidify a robotic arm
stacks the mold trays in a holding area
the arm gently lowers the trays into
place for several hours the pills
continue to harden in the molds once
completely solidified the gummy vitamins
are removed from the molds and
transferred into a revolving drum the
tumble in the drum separates them they
exit onto a perforated conveyor and any
small bits fall through the holes that
conveyor zigzags back and forth allowing
the gummy vitamins to cool and further
solidify the gummy vitamins have now
reached their final consistency
the gummy vitamins head into a steam
chamber the humidity from the steam
preps the vitamins for sugar coating the
sugar clings to the gummy vitamins and
the revolving action of the drum shakes
off any excess leaving just a dusting on
the surface at the packaging station the
vitamins funnel into shoots where
sensors count and release the pills into
bottles as the bottles move forward caps
land on the rims and spinning rubber
mechanisms screw the caps on tightly
down the line labels with product
information are placed onto each bottle
[Music]
depending on the formulation it can take
up to three weeks to produce gummy
vitamin pills and the result nutritious
gumdrops that are a real treat